salut les mentale aux petites vidéos
tranquille à 6 pourquoi pas je vous fais
cette vidéo très tôt ce matin parce que
je pars faire deux tournages après
aujourd'hui dans la journée donc si je
la tête du mec pas très réveillé s'est
pas totalement faux aujourd'hui je
voulais vous parler de cinq choses qu'on
voit sur notre visage de ce que dit
notre visage pas forcément les
micro-expressions qui elles traduisent
des émotions mais on voit bien plus que
ça sur le visage de quelqu'un
premièrement on sait si vous êtes plutôt
quelqu'un de terre à terre plutôt
quelqu'un porté vers l'artistique
vous savez que sur les photos on a
toujours son profil préféré en tout cas
la plupart d'entre vous ont un profil
préféré un montre en australie du sud
owen cherche a fait une étude là dessus
et cette étude a démontré de manière
scientifique statistiques et rationnelle
ceux qui préfèrent montrer leur côté
droit ou qui spontanément mettre leur
profil droit sont plutôt des
scientifiques des mathématiciens des
personnes qui sont très pragmatiques
très logique alors que celles qui
expriment leurs émotions donc on va dire
plutôt les créatifs montrent leur côté
gauche ne me demandez pas pourquoi on
n'a pas la réponse et une recherche
statistique qui a été fait je vous dis
ça je ne savais pas non plus à en
faisant des recherches pour cette vidéo
que j'ai découvert ça et du coup je vais
m'atteler à faire attention à ça
aujourd'hui et je verrai si ma propre
expérience est en accord avec cette
étude deuxième chose on voit également
ce que vous mangez suivant la coloration
de la peau si vous avez la peau un petit
peu orangé c'est pas forcément vous avez
fait des uv c'est aussi parce que vous
mangez correctement et que vous avez
beaucoup de carotène en vous la carotène
c'est une particule qu'on retrouve dans
la carotte et qui donne cette jolie
couleur au visage
c'est un petit peu plus jaune quand même
que la mélanine et ça se repère
facilement et bien les psychologues de
l'université de leeds et seule
l'université de saint-andrews ils ont
fait la même étude en même temps en 2014
se sont aperçus que ces visages là était
plus attrayant que les visages bronzés
c'est à dire qu inconsciemment nous
sommes aussi programmés pour être
attirés par des personnes qui ont une
alimentation saine regarder les visages
et vous aussi vous serez si votre voisin
mouche de la carotte ou une bonne
alimentation
troisième chose on voit sur le visage la
manière dont les personnes se battent
c'est encore plus vrai pour les hommes
la vraie chose à regarder c'est la
largeur du visage par rapport à la
hauteur de la personne plus le visage
est large proportionnellement à la
taille de la personne plus en général
c'est un bon combattant c'est un bon
bout de temps bon bourrin et moi j'ai le
visage bien fin donc s'il vous plaît ne
malgré ses pas donc je disais
quatrièmement une des choses qu'on peut
voir sur le visage et qui aussi
intéressante à prendre en compte c'est
la personne face à la douleur sur des
douleurs très rapide fulgurant goût sur
des douleurs un petit peu plus longue
qu'elle soit physique ou émotionnel il
se passe beaucoup de choses dans cette
région là en fait ce qui se passe c'est
que quand on a mal on commence à froncer
comme ça mais c'est plus léger que ce
que je suis en train de faire c'est dur
à maîtriser mais quand quelqu'un de
votre entourage par exemple dit qu'il a
mal et qu'il a besoin des dexter vous
pouvez regarder dans cette région pour
voir l'intensité de la douleur c'est
très dur de jauger comme ça par la
parole l'intensité de la douleur de
quelqu'un vous pouvez le faire en
regardant sur son visage des signes et
des traces de la douleur plutôt que
d'essayer de jauger par la voix et même
si au départ vous n'avez pas de point de
départ quand la personne vous dit
qu'elle a mal vous pouvez regarder son
visage et essayer de voir toutes les
crispations de cette zone ici au dessus
des yeux et de le prendre comme point de
référence pour voir si dix minutes après
la personne a plus ou moins mal si elle
france de plus en plus ou de moins en
moins et enfin cinquièmement et c'est
une étude que je viens de découvrir
assez récemment qui est très
intéressante à l'ailier non pas au micro
expressions mais on est un petit peu sur
le même travail
on peut découvrir ce à quoi vient de
réagir une personne c'est à dire que on
voit là une réaction sur le visage de
quelqu'un et on est capable de remonter
ce à quoi elle vient de réagir par
exemple est ce qu'on vient de lui
annoncer une triste nouvelle ou est ce
qu'on vient lui demander de patienter
dans une salle d'attenté ou ce genre de
choses et ça c'est intéressant parce
qu'au delà de l'émotion on arrive à
caractériser un fait c'est l'université
de nottingham en 2012 qui a fait ses
études là et ils ont demandé un panel de
personnes
le regardais des courtes vidéos il n'y
avait pas de son et de dire d'après eux
ce à quoi la personne réagisse et ils
ont eu 60% de bonnes réponses et quand
même beaucoup 60 % de réponses et pour
faire une phase test de comparaison
puisqu'il pouvait pas vraiment avoir un
panel placebo on va dire il avait
organisé un qcm donc il y avait des
réponses où ils pouvaient cochet parmi
toutes ces réponses laquelle était la
bonne
et si on s'en tient aux statistiques du
qcm il aurait dû avoir à peine 20 % de
bonnes réponses si ç'avait été
complètement au hasard il ya vraiment un
écart qui permet de dire que non c'est
pas a priori notre premier critère
spontanée et de regarder toute la région
de la bouche et les réactions au niveau
de la bouche je vous avoue que c'est
quelque chose que je connais les
réactions qu'on a au niveau au niveau
des lèvres mais pas assez pour
l'associer comme ça à des réactions très
défini dans l'étude par exemple ils ont
une 90% de bonnes réponses pour les gens
à qui on demandait d'attendre une
patiente et c'est beaucoup c'est
tellement beau coup que j'ai commandé
l'étude
je vais la lire
va est en anglais donc ça est un petit
peu long de bien tout comprendre qui est
spécifique je vais l'étudier en retirer
ce qu'ils en retirent et je vous ferai
une nouvelle vidéo dessus
eh bien j'espère que cette vidéo un
petit peu matinale pour moi mais qui est
à 17 heures comme d'habitude pour vous
vous a plu si c'est le cas mettez un
pouce en l'air vraiment et puis genre
offrait aussi dans ce style là comme ça
ça me sert toujours aussi à voir si ça
vous a vraiment plu ou pas merci
beaucoup d'avoir regardé la vidéo vous
pouvez la compléter d'un petit
commentaire sur ce sujet ça me fait
toujours plaisir de le dire parce que je
lis oui tous les commentaires oui tous
dans les petites news d'ici la fin de la
semaine je sors la vidéo sur les my maps
vous mandat avait envoyé plein c'est top
la semaine prochaine fait faire un
concours avec cinq choses à gagner qui
sont plutôt cool on me l'a proposé
aujourd'hui c'est pas partenariat parce
que je touche pas d'argent ou quoi que
ce soit c'est vraiment l'occasion en
fait de vous faire des cadeaux et je
suis très content de ça dc de la fin de
la semaine y aura également une grande
nouvelle sur la chaîne les vraiment à
l'eau savent de quoi je parle
et puis pensez à partager cette vidéo
pourquoi pas et vous abonner avant de
partir si ce n'est pas déjà fait puisque
le mental blog sait déjà c'est grâce à
vous qu'on est aussi nombreux merci
voilà je vous le dis merci et rendez
vous demain à 17h ciao
[Musique]